on vous en parlait il ya quelques
semaines il y a en ce moment un
ralentissement dans le marché immobilier
à montréal les prix ont même légèrement
baissé dans certains quartiers et on
disait en fait c'est parce qu'il y avait
trop de condos avant trop de condos sur
le marché montréalais or erreur dans
quelques années nous dit on ira encore
plus de condos mais des condos de luxe
françois korber il lianke à circuler
quelques minutes entre ces maquettes
pour s'apercevoir que le visage de
montréal est appelé à changer énorme
comme ça une association de
propriétaires immobiliers veut montrer
que montréal est l'endroit idéal pour
investir ou le marché est en
effervescence en ce moment il ya qu'il
ya 1 2 3 4 sur 5 en septembre
cinq grands taux de gratte ciel menaçant
et que ce soit sur l'avenue des
canadiens sur le boulevard rené-lévesque
ouest où dans green town énormément de
condos de luxe alors que le marché des
condos est à la baisse
beaucoup de gens de 50 ans et plus
seraient tentés de vendre leur maison
pour revenir en ville
selon ce vendeur eux vont pas jeter un
petit con 12 500 pieds carrés qui était
propice dans les dernières années pour
le premier acheteur star des
investissements qui essentiellement se
concentrent dans l'ouest du centre ville
en ce moment les gros projets des grosse
tôle et les grands à faire en ce moment
en ce moment là c'est à l'ouest là
personnel rares sont les projets à l'est
et la plupart du temps ce sont louis des
condos mais plus abordable
ce qu'on aime bien une chance de prendre
un quartier défavorisé le tournoi un
quartier qui fleurissent à qui a même
des commerces quand même
la vie alentour bien que cette
entreprise propose un méga chantier de
260 millions un nouveau toit pour le
stade olympique qui coûterait selon eux
moins cher que ce qui est discuté
actuellement parce qu'ils seraient
autoportant tout et aux touailles ont
été proposés adhap irakien de
renforcement des structures de béton et
du mans mais l'idée de doter le stade
nouveau toit est loin de faire
l'unanimité
ici françois cormier radio canada
montréal